lemurs are the most ancient primate
alive today and Madagascar is the only
place on earth where they live this film
shows the lemurs from all different
areas in Madagascar it's a wonderful
voyage to be able to see the different
habitat types and to see the different
kinds of lemurs some of these animals
have never been in movies before they're
spectacular they're smart they're
beautiful they have character they're
unusual there's so many of them and
they're so different
they're totally irresistible these
lemurs are very engaging creatures of
the forest
Madagascar because Pat Wright was able
to preserve Ramanathan National Park and
we're able to see species which are
larger and stranger than almost any
other rainforest in the world you escape
into an ancient world when you go into
the forest these species all around you
that are found nowhere else all
interacting together this place is full
of things nobody's ever seen before
one of the most incredibly effective
teaching tools believe in that smoovies
it's a really professional crew that
could really capture the lives of the
animals for the whole world and that's
that's great Dave Douglas is sort of
this mad scientist of IMAX in that he
brings with him to location incredible
arrangement of gear and he's pretty
focused not on what sort of you were
shiny it's more on what will work one of
the things that we found was this device
called the cinebulle which is a balloon
which has been developed and adapted as
a camera platform it has a few talents
that no other aircraft has the first
time an IMAX production has ever used a
balloon for filming and that was pretty
extraordinary flight plan is to take off
and make sure that we can actually level
properly and then fly through these bare
Bob's and land in small village with us
crashing
it reminds me of The Wizard of Oz when
that guy's taken off and waving and not
knowing where he's gonna wind up
Madagascar is the size of Texas of
France so it's a huge island so you're
trying to get to someplace that's remote
and it's almost impossible there's parts
of his films that I watch and every time
I watch it I'm still amazed that there
it is on the screen
what makes Madagascar a great adventure
for a filmmaker is some of the things
that are not there there is no road
system there of any particular kinds
it's chances that you're gonna get
somewhere is always an adventure
there's no airports there's no roads
there is no way to get around you know
the vast majority of the country it's
totally inaccessible
Madagascar is a real challenge and to
make a film like this in Madagascar is
just America
to make this movie really come together
like we relied on the people of
Madagascar the lemurs of Madagascar the
scientists from all over the world
Madagascar is such an unknown quantity
we had to figure out what we could make
it from about and then figure out how to
make that film and we've got elements
which have never been used together and
we've got new cameras which have never
been used in the field at all we can
grab animal behavior and would always
missed in the past in the film years
they are living in extremely dramatic
time and Earth's history in their long
history it's a come-from-behind survival
story that highlights their ability to
survive and the uncertainties of the
world that they're presented with now
there are little ones big ones and
dancing ones and singing ones I should
do that with a maximum lemurs are
extraordinary animals it's time that
everyone knew how great lemurs are
island of lemurs Madagascar exclusively
in IMAX theaters
you